eu vou compartilhar com vocês
a história de como a educação
revolucionou a minha vida e de como hoje
eu tenho buscado contribuir com uma
revolução para melhorar a qualidade da
educação
eu sou jornalista trabalhei muitos anos
como repórter que era o meu grande sonho
profissional em vários lugares do brasil
mas eu sempre tive uma inquietação que é
com o comportamento que eu chamo de
curiosidade mórbida
o que faz as pessoas se interessarem
pela desgraça alheia
eu não estou falando das grandes
tragédias de um desabamento de uma
enchente
não estou falando do cotidiano vou dar
um exemplo o corpo estendido no chão
eu não sei se vocês já tiveram a
oportunidade eu sinceramente espero que
não porque é uma cena horrível mas numa
cena de crime quando tem um corpo
estendido no chão fica um monte de gente
em volta
conversando passando tempo quantas e
quantas vezes eu não cheguei para fazer
uma reportagem e tinha até crianças
o facto da escola e eu não aguentava eu
sempre procurava o responsável pai mãe
avô avó e falava escuta a escola a
depois a gente vai se conhece esses são
parentes e tal conhece morto não tem
algum depoimento para da polícia para
ajudar
não a gente estava só passando e
resolveu ficar aqui em pernambuco mesmo
no ano de 2005 aconteceu outro fato que
me marcou muito
lavan da funasa tinha trazido aqui para
o recife do sertão
um grupo de índios que vieram fazer
exames médicos no retorno
essa voz sofreu um acidente e capotou
caiu num riacho e 19 pessoas morreram
inclusive
um dos bombeiros que estava fazendo
resgatados
foi uma cena horrível porque para
resgatar essa vã
demorou o dia todo era muita chuva no
meio da estrada e quando conseguiram
finalmente já estava escuro ea chuva não
parar e na hora do resgate da van quando
guindastes ou aquela van e colocou no
meio da estrada
tinha tanta gente foco que a polícia
rodoviária a equipe de resgate os
jornalistas não conseguiam trabalhar
porque as pessoas empurravam eu me
lembro de dois policiais ameaçando de
pedir às pessoas para que elas parassem
de empurrar umas às outras e a gente
olhava para trás e fazia se conhece não
vai sai da frente que eu quero ver a
gota d'água para mim aconteceu num
sábado de manhã muito sol daqueles dias
que não tem uma nuvem no céu num
cemitério 11 horas da manhã eu tinha
como missão empresa estar a mãe de um
adolescente assassinado no velório
quando eu entrei profundamente
constrangida por mais que eu tentasse
ser discreta
quando você trabalha com televisão não
dá muito porque vê o equipamento e pro
phone
quando eu entrei as pessoas me olharam
inclusive a mãe eu não sabia quem era a
mãe mas não é muito difícil identificar
quem é a mãe do morto no velório e
aquela mulher olhou pra mim sem que eu
dissesse nada e falou minha filha o que
você quer que eu diga pra você eu não
sei o que eu estou sentindo
lavras nunca mais saíram de mim naquele
momento eu decidi que eu não ia me
acostumar a passar pelos sentimentos dos
outros não ia passar por cima que tipo
de prestação de serviço é essa pra que
eu estava enterrando os sentimentos
daquela mulher antes que o enterrasse o
próprio filho
não deu
e foi nesse momento que a educação
entrou na minha vida num profundo
momento de desilusão profissional com a
profissão dos meus sonhos eu recebi um
convite pra dar aula de comunicação numa
faculdade eu não sabia direito o que
esperar
conversei com algumas pessoas algumas me
disseram assim vai é legal e outras tá
doido
você sabe quanto ganha o professor
eu fui e aí é até difícil segurar o
sorriso porque eu me lembro da sensação
do meu primeiro dia na sala de aula do
que é ser professor
gente que é isso que sensação é essa que
você olhar e eram alunos assim de
primeiro semestre e até hoje eu tenho
essa mesma sensação que você está tão
fantástica de compartilhar informações
interessantes para pessoas interessadas
é mágico
é fantástico mas a gente realmente se
inspirar perdeu fôlego e eu sou tomada
pelo orgulho de ser professora
tenho vontade de andar com isso na testa
brilho mas com o passar períodos dos
semestres
eu comecei a ser tomada também por uma
estranheza e se achar que eu era meio o
peixe fora d'água
muito empolgada porque eu sou do tipo de
professor que pergunta se o aluno está
precisando alguma coisa daí meio do
telefone sem problemas mas ouvindo
discursos de outros professores
às vezes eu ouvia coisas assim
ah não dá viu zé roberto mais aquela
turma pelo amor de deus tem vontade de
mandar matar todinho mudar se a galera
toda desinteressada ninguém quer nada
com nada
naquele momento eu voltei os olhos para
os alunos e comecei a perceber prestar
atenção o que eles achavam dos
professores e ouvir coisas do mesmo tipo
pelo amor de deus em essa mulher é muito
mal amada carrasca esse cara não vale
nada
esse professor lhe falem o nome dele
eu comecei a perguntar para os alunos
porque a gente ainda mais numa faculdade
e dá lhe dando informação lugar que deve
borbulhar motivação porque está abrindo
as suas portas que ajudando a estruturar
a sua carreira ter esse nível de
relacionamento entre professor e aluno
porque naquele momento
uma das alternativas que eu encontrei de
contribuir para melhorar isso foi
perguntar para os alunos o que eles
achavam e aí eles dizem que têm muita
dificuldade de apresentar trabalho do
professor que não entendia o que eles
diziam que eles tinham dificuldade de
escrever e tal eu comecei a oferecer
cursos livres dentro mesmo da disciplina
de comunicação clareza e objetividade
como passar as suas ideias para o papel
de modo organizado redação como perder o
medo de falar em público para apresentar
trabalhos e deu muito certo foi muito
legal eu passei muito tempo fazendo isso
e deu tão certo que alguns professores
começaram a me procurar porque eles
também tinham interesse de melhorar essa
comunicação com os outros alunos com os
alunos
foi eu passei um tempão só fazendo isso
inclusive porque cresceu e foi demais
porque eles também estavam incomodados
muitos professores inclusive também
incomodados com a falência do
relacionamento em sala de aula
então eu resolvi dar um passo mais à
frente e fazer uma investigação
científica sobre esse relacionamento
entre professor e aluno
eu ingressei em ingressar no mestrado da
universidade federal de pernambuco e foi
lá e se abriram as portas pra mim de uma
outra oportunidade é o portal a
possibilidade de contribuir com uma
revolução e já está em curso na educação
em uma das primeiras reuniões que eu
tive depois que eu entrei no mestrado
com o meu orientador aurino lima
ferreira um brilhante professor ainda
hoje meu orientador no doutorado ele me
disse assim mariana você já percebeu que
as emoções estão na base da comunicação
mas você já notou que não tem espaço
para as emoções na escola é verdade
o sistema vigente educacional hoje a
escola hoje nos obriga a sua entrar com
cérebro como se fosse possível como se
eu tivesse por acaso um dispositivo eu
deixo tudo bem eu sou todas as minhas
emoções e todo o resto e entrou só para
aprender a ler e escrever somar e
decorar o resto deixa de fora
será que dá será que é possível isso não
é possível
a revolução está em curso hoje prata
dessa integralidade do ser humano eu sou
muito mais do que os meus pensamentos
eu sou também um ser que sonha que me
emociona que comporta o existe uma
integração entre sentir pensar
agir e não pode ser desprezada
o ser humano é dotado de uma
complexidade de uma integralidade e
precisa ser incluída na escola eu
desenvolvi uma ilustração para deixar
isso um pouco mais claro para nos ajudar
a pensar será que eu também não sou um
pouco das minhas angústias
será que eu não entro também com os meus
medos que às vezes são infantis ou da
minha ansiedade as minhas preocupações
será que eu não entro com isso na sala
de aula
será que eu também não entro com parte
da minha criação que às vezes pode ter
sido muito repressor amht eu pedi pra
fazer essa ilustração com a figura
masculina de propósito quantas vezes a
gente não diz o homem não chora menino
cala boca engole o choro é porque eu
consigo deixar mesmo isso de fora
quando eu estou na escola
será que eu consigo deixar de fora do
ambiente escolar
o resto do meu corpo as doenças que às
vezes eu desenvolvi o que eu tenho o meu
estresse é possível quando os casos de
bullying a gente não vê que começam por
aspectos físicos dos outros e os meus
relacionamentos
se eu sou o tipo de pessoa que só se
resolver as coisas no grito
eu sou visto assim será que só porque eu
entrei na sala de aula as pessoas vão
achar que eu estou apenas entrando com a
minha inteligência ou cérebro dá mesmo
pra deixar de fora
acho que não felizmente a gente sabe que
hoje existem
pesquisas que mostram muito o quanto nós
podemos avançar o quanto nós precisamos
a nos estados unidos e na espanha
principalmente o desenvolvimento das
habilidades sócio-emocionais está mais
rápido
eles já sabem que para cada 1 dólar
investido nos estados unidos
outros 11 são economizados em prevenção
de violência e agressividade dos
problemas de relacionamentos
interpessoais porque tem algo importante
que se diga a educação emocional ela não
é um campo para autoajuda de balcão não
é frase feita de rede social não é uma
cartilha com fórmula mágica pra todo
mundo educação emocional é fruto de
pesquisa de estudo e no brasil nós já
temos muitos pesquisadores trabalhando
arduamente para desenvolver isso nas
escolas na própria universidade federal
de pernambuco no núcleo de educação
espiritualidade na universidade federal
da paraíba no núcleo de educação
emocional no instituto de formação
humana que é uma associação sem fins
lucrativos formadas por professores
doutores que pesquisam sobre a
integralidade e nos ajudam a pensar que
tipo de ser humano a escola está
ajudando a formar quem são essas pessoas
bom a minha parte nesta revolução a
minha contribuição eu tenho buscado
fazer em primeiro lugar ajudando a
divulgar usando meu lado de comunicadora
que nunca saiu de mim ajudando a
divulgar gratuitamente essas pesquisas
científicas para que elas tenham cada
vez mais visibilidade e também tentado
construir um projeto de educação
emocional integral e tem como proposta
lugar promover a alfabetização emocional
é preciso que as escolas ensinem a lidar
com as emoções
a saber nomeá las corretamente assim
como a gente
se na lei escrever somar
é preciso que as pessoas aprendam
inclusive a interpretar os gestos a
comunicação não verbal ou será que o
professor que passa o tempo inteiro de
costas não tem nada a dizer
o aluno que me olha com o peixe lá em
cima
será que ele não passa mais nenhuma
mensagem com a alfabetização emocional
a gente pode favorecer o
autoconhecimento significa entender como
se dá essa integração entre sentir
pensar e agir quando eu estou tomado
pela raiva o que acontece comigo como
são os meus pensamentos como é que eu me
comporto até para que eu consiga
estimular a transcendência acolher as
minhas sombras e superá las porque assim
eu vou conseguir estimular a autogestão
a gestão das minhas emoções porque nem
pesquisa a gente sabe que educação
emocional
as emoções não tem controle ao contrário
do que se diz por aí
emoção tem uma função de regulação de
adaptação eu não consigo tirar as minhas
emoções controlá-las reprimi las
é como tentar tirar o meu nariz não dá
mas eu posso geri las de modo eficiente
e produtivo e conectando com as outras
pessoas para face a decisões
responsáveis e na minha visão é uma das
grandes metas da educação conseguir
estimular um ser humano a tomar decisões
responsáveis importantes para si e para
o outro de modo contributivo empático
estabelecendo uma escuta sensível e que
vise o bem estar com eu luto eu acredito
muito que a educação emocional precisa
estar em todos os projetos pedagógicos
ela precisa estar na formação de
professores ela precisa fazer parte do
curry
ela precisa vir a política pública
porque assim a educação vai ajudar a
cumprir seu papel de formar seres
humanos melhores e eu espero que quando
isso acontecer à medida que isso vai
acontecendo a gente fique cada vez mais
longe de ver pessoas tirando o self
tendo como paisagem de fundo a desgraça
alheia é isso
obrigada
[Aplausos]